قال وزير خارجيا الايطالي انطونيو يعني
عندما يحدث في ايران فاقا كل تصورات
واضافت يعني وفك وفق ما نقلت وكاله نوفا
الايطاليه انه سيقوم باستدعاء السفير
الايراني الى وزاره الخارجيه عندما يتولى
منصبه في روما معتبرا ان ما يحدث في ايران
غير مقبول وفق تعبيره
اعلن موقع وهران المعني بحقوق الانسان في
ايران ان عدد المتظاهرين المحكوم عليهم
بالاعدام او المعتقلين المعرضين لخطر
الحكم عليهم بلغ 58 شخصا وفي التفاصيل تم
الحكم على 11 شخص اخر بالاعدام بينما
يواجهه 47
تهاما قد تؤدي الى عقوبه الاعدام وبحسب
التقرير فهنالك امراه امراه من بين
المتهمين المعرضين لخطر الاعدام
ضع خرابه 500 ممثل ومخرج وعامل في مجال
السينما العالميه من بينهم النجمتان كي
تونسلت وماريون كوتيا في رساله لسلطات
الايرانيه دعو الى الافراج فورا عن
الممثله تراني اليدوستي اليدوستي التي
اعتقلت لدعمها الاحتجاجات في ايران وتقول
رساله المفتوحه عند توقيت اعتقال اليدوستي
البالغه من العمر 38 عاما قبيله عيد
الميلاد كان متعمدا لضمان
زملائها حول العالم وكانت الممثله تراني
نددت باول اعدام في الاحتجاجات الاخيره
بحق المتظاهر محسن شكري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]